on va où là là on était en train de
pêcher il ya une personne qui veut de
nous voir et nous a dit qu'elle fait
tomber son téléphone il ya environ trois
jours donc dans l'eau dans un bocal
pêcher dans le canal voit là dessus
cette personne tu va nous emmener en bas
du téléphone et on va essayer de le
sortir
il nous a donné rendez vous ici c'est le
mot personnes ouais mon au câble on va
le chercher
bon alors mission de sauvetage donc à
vous fait chier et il est tombé de la
poche plus de moins ouais ouais ici
j'essaye les films quand sadio une
seconde main quoi une heure qui passe
ton travail tu devrais je le voyais la
téléphonie l'affairé
[Musique]
il a rebondi
ouais non après le téléphone pour de la
chance quand même on met un peu l'avant
et ça n'a pas bougé
temps forts il ya des petits morceaux de
termes pour la carte sim
c'est compliqué
j'y crois pas trop on cherche un
portable la new wave la recherchent un
portable qui est tombée on a tous fait
des ordinateurs on a déjà fait on va du
coup on abandonne les mains parce que le
samsung met pas ses menteries je vais
aller à tâtonnements avec les mains
quatorze coups de fond donc ça devrait
le faire
c'est parti
on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu mais on n'a
pas pu retrouver le portable donc on
réussira peut-être avec un détecteur de
métaux et avec un les stages parce que
l'avant c'était hyper compliqué de
rester au fond et on attaque un petit
peu ce nouveau prétendant du potentiel
après c'est pas très profond là il ya de
la variété est donc c'est un peu parce
que ça sonne donc travail sous le pont
on peut mieux au bar banane regarder
mont comi tiercé lourd parce que ça
c'est un homme chauve c'est parce que ça
frotte sur la base c'est pas si loin
mais super houioux fils épouse
le cadre est super large ouais ok
superbe
il sera vendu à la terreur c'est dommage
de l'autre la numéro de série comment tu
sais la salle une grosse étiquette avec
un numéro là henri bourassa n'a pas
d'autre selon l'avait senti plusieurs
fois quand même en tirant mieux là bas
allez vu le ras le bol c'est sympa mais
oui à l'erreur regarde c'est venu ou
dommages
on est souvent c'est une kalachnikov
oui toujours qu'une kalachnikov alors ça
peut être une caisse une dragonne off
alors quand est tellement franchement si
la silla tu sens la lance roquettes a
tué le game je mange un fils doit
surtout dans ce petit village et je
pense qu'à plein de vélos c'est pas le
truc de talent tels que j'ai eu cette
lettre au centre du tapis de jeu inscrit
dans l'accord de l'autre qui tirent et
oui on l'avait annoncé je crois par
contre la hausse du coût de la voiture
ça commence à être compliquée voit
effectivement attentive aux vaches mans
utile et vachement utile et l'autre
location tu crois c'est dommage et on
passe du bios des limites sur celui des
limites aux siens dans la chaîne et tous
ces morts mais lire le cadre s'il a ses
limites
le cadre est limité à s'arracher
j'ai quand même un morceau je crois ce
que j'aurais pas arracher une celles qui
n'étaient pas bien serré quand vous
jetez vos vélos les gars resserrer la
scène mon post du bois
alors de pêche ça c'est cool ça c'est
cool et oui du coup à notre faute qui
lui a donné un de leurs tu lui a donné
un autre pote la paperie cela il est
comme neuf
voilà bon francis si tu nous regardes on
attend leur bon qu'on se retrouve
l'autre côté du pont yes bon vent ce qui
reste des vélos on s'est mis ici pour
les attrapés pour éviter qu'ils se
bloque contre la pente du rock c'était
déjà faire un petit hans et la tension
au moment de vérité le pont est il déjà
tu es peut-être que le bois il m'a
empêchée d'avoir leur est propre là ok
ça paye vélo ou qu'est ce que c'est que
ça par le boom des positions là le petit
sachet de lait petit bébé chien c'est
cher aussi
moi tu vas me choper les vélos ainsi
pour le chopper je te laisse faire très
très sympa ce petit port là
on est posée dommage que l'instinct n'a
pas pu venir
il y avait un anniversaire
la prochaine pour départ n'était pas en
forme
bon les vélos baptiste meneghin met de
côté pour que pg lo hélas n'a pas touché
un seul tu vas aller faire le tour tu
vas faire choper les vélos bayonne
franchement faudrait un bon mètre de
plus pour être sur une grille ça c'est
pour le baroque et un antivol couper
plus alors de pêche
c'est ce qu'on appelle une belle fête m
échappe cheap mais sans les vélos se
plaît je vois que c'est une belle pêche
regarde regarde moi sa nouvelle non mais
c'est de la fonte attentes un peu je
m'en mords moi je voulais rester l'autre
côté pour les avoir sa vie il s'était
plus simple
envol antivol face à aux curés c'est
trop cool ch iffre baptiste ce soir
s'ils essaient de nous déchirer sa
surface entre un bon et un boost est
quelque chose d'autre web ou de vélo
adacore tempo ou émaillé et à leur sympa
petit leur ai apprécié atteindre bomba a
tenté pour le vélo on revient demain
soleil à rasta qui nous attend à la
maison
il doit avoir envie de pisser à mon avis
à les battre
à suivre c'est dégueulasse mais les
vélos on aime bien les péchés mais les
mène dans la voiture c'est toujours un
peu le bordel c'est horrible en plus là
c'est la partie qu'on voit mais en fait
ça coule tout 7 20 ce qui s'écoule par
scellement faut cotiser les gars pour
comptage et un cyber trucks
j'étais assis vers craque donc voilà
j'ai prévu pour de le pré commander pour
une livraison en 2021 2022
donc c'est environ 40000 dollars d'après
ce que j'ai compris si vous donnez tous
un dollar on est bons tous les abonnés
de dollars et on aura un cyber trucks à
la fin de l'année hu